We have mentioned
the former president
once again made history today,
becoming the very first former
president of the United States of America
to ever be arrested
and arraigned in a federal court
and the first to face federal charges
before heading into court today, Mr.
Trump wrote on his social media
site, quote,
One of the saddest days
in the history of the country, unquote.
I think that that's true,
although probably not in the way
he intended it.
Joining me,
two people who know
about another sad and historic moment,
the Watergate scandal.
Legendary investigative journalist
and author of Chasing History
A Kid in the NEWSROOM, Carl Bernstein.
Also with me
is CNN contributor and former counsel
for the Nixon White House.
John Dean.
Carl, first,
I just want to get your reaction
to what happened
today, these historic images
out of Miami.
Donald Trump arriving at the courthouse.
What went through your mind
watching it all?
That we're being
tested in this country
in a way that we never have been before.
Then our political institutions
are being tested.
The Republican Party is being tested,
that the judicial system
is being tested, that all of the elements
of who we are as a people
are being tested.
As a result of one man's recklessness.
One man's not caring about
what he does as president
of the United States
to the country,
but rather his own interests
throughout his presidency
and the recklessness
and disregard
for truth, for established procedure.
And what's so stunning to me
today is to hear
from the Republican Party.
And this is one of the great differences
with Watergate,
where the Republican Party
eventually coalesced
against Richard Nixon
and said a criminal president
of the United States had to leave office.
We don't see that happening now.
Rather, what we see is this indictment.
Trump several
Republicans are saying, yeah, he did it.
It's evident from the indictment
he did it.
He did those things.
It's incontrovertible.
And yet they're trying to make the issue,
the judiciary,
the president of the United States,
Hunter Biden, Hillary Clinton.
What about the criminal acts
that are incontrovertible?
In this document and made so clear
in that courtroom?
John Dean, the former
president's codefendant,
while Nada is an interesting figure
in all of this,
he did not enter a plea today.
He did not have an attorney from Florida.
His arraignment will be later this month.
What do you make of that?
Donald Trump shows up with attorneys.
They are co-defendants.
Walton on a does not have an attorney
Well, I remember when
there was another group
of coconspirators who after Watergate,
certainly went their own direction
and did not hang out together.
So it's kind of surprising.
I think if he had a good lawyer,
he'd be telling him
that he ought to be doing his own thing
and strike his own pose.
So it was a little bit confusing
that he is hanging and tidy.
I guess he's still employed by Mr. Trump.
He is still his valet,
and he doesn't seem to appreciate that.
Mr.
Trump is the one who got him
in the whole heap of trouble he's in
and he is in a heap of trouble.
So it was unusual today,
a member of the saying the aphorism,
no man is a hero to his valet,
but that might not be true
in the case of Mr.
Nader, he might actually still be quite
enamored of Mr. Trump. John?
Who do you think the obstruction case
is more clear cut against
what Nana or Donald Trump
Well, with a conspiracy,
all you have to do is show
that there is a mutual agreement, either
openly or by tacitly
to commit a criminal act.
I think there is
the evidence is pretty strong.
They both agreed
to undertake these activities
and did the first step
In fact,
they did many steps
to implement the conspiracy.
So I think
that charge is going to be very easy.
It's a favorite
of the federal prosecutors
they use 80 USC three 71 regularly,
and that's the one they're charged under.
So I think that
the conspiracy count is probably equal
I think the obstruction count
is certainly stronger against Mr.
Trump.
Karl, immediately after his arrest
and arraignment,
Donald Trump stopped at a Cuban-American
cafe in Miami where he was greeted
by supporters,
greeted by religious leaders.
They had a little prayer circle for him.
Then he flew to New Jersey.
He's holding a fundraiser
in Bedminster this evening.
Does this behavior surprise you at all?
Not in the least.
There's every bit of evidence
that this event,
these indictments, plural, and others
in all likelihood
to come work to his advantage.
So far,
in terms of who Republican voters are.
There was just some comment
a couple of moments ago
about when Iowa, the primary,
the caucuses,
and primaries there
in New Hampshire occur.
Everybody I've talked to Republicans
and I've talked to more Republicans
today, and I have Democrats
see that this is working to Trump's
advantage electorally.
But there are some subtle shifts.
We heard Chris Sununu tonight
on this earlier broadcast,
and he makes great sense.
But are fellow Republicans
going to go along and don't dump Trump?
We don't see much evidence of that.
And a really horrible thing is
what is the Republican Party
stand for today?
If this law and order party
is willing to go along with a president
who has broken the law
throughout his presidency,
who is being indicted in multiple cases
with incontrovertible evidence
of what he did?
Might he be acquitted by a jury?
Sure. But is the evidence there?
Has it been there
in terms of what he did?
Let's look at January 6th.
We know what he did.
Republicans know what he did.
So the question becomes,
what about the rule of law
in this country?
And is one party
ready to scuttle the principle
of the rule of law
being paramount in our culture
and in our politics?
John Dean,
the former president, is quoted
in the indictment saying, quote,
I don't want anybody
looking through my boxes,
unquote, and also, quote,
wouldn't it be better
if we just told them
we don't have anything here?
These are comments
he made to his attorneys.
There's also apparently an audio
recording of him telling Mark Meadows
autobiography is that the document
he is showing them
is secret, that he could,
when he was president,
could he could he could declassify it.
But since he's no longer president,
he had no ability to do so.
Do you see any parallels to
the Watergate tape
where Nixon is heard plotting
with his chief of staff?
Well, of course, almost
virtually every conversation
that Nixon had, he had over
a thousand conversations
that were recorded,
some of them as short as 5 minutes.
Some of them 8 hours, one of them
where he's talking about Watergate.
So the volume certainly is much vaster
with Nixon
but these are quite incriminating
and very powerful evidence,
the ones that they've got,
some of those the tapes are Mr.
Cochran himself
giving his recollection of meetings
and apparently simultaneously
with the events are relatively close
based on notes.
Those are going to be contested,
I'm sure, in this criminal trial.
They'll probably try
to get those thrown out,
as George Conway was suggesting.
I think that's
one of their strategies
to get eliminate those.
So anyway,
tapes are always very powerful
for juries.
And there were about 12
of them were played
during the trial of Haldeman,
Erlichman, Mitchell at all,
who were Nixon's closest aides.
And they were
very persuasive to the jury Hmm.
John Dean, Carl
Bernstein, thank you so much.